- OK, numerous nights and days
that you think about leaving the bubble.
I think everyone has, including you guys.
- [Laughing]
- [Reporter:] Well, I'm
being serious.
- Well, I'm just saying,
I don't think there's not one
person that has not had a mind
that says, “Oh, I gotta
get the hell out of here.”
- That bus ain’t left?
- It's gone.
- Fuck!
Man.
- [Laughing]
- Oh, thank you. You talk to Callie?
- I did! I said, I was like,
“Are you gonna come to the bubble?”
But she's not.
- Oh no, I was telling her she
is not coming to the bubble.
We’re gonna make sure of it.
- She's on vacation.
- [Announcer:] Welcome to
Orlando. The local time is 10:33.
- Good shit.
- Thank you.
- Hey, Tacko. [Laughing]
Thank you.
- I had to bring it out.
- OK, so while I'm waiting for sound,
I'm trying to draft my fantasy team.
This is multitasking in the bubble.
So, I have been in the
bubble since July 12.
There have been good moments, bad moments,
lonely moments, happy moments.
It's just been a big
roller coaster of emotions.
But we are now here, and it is the start
of Round 2 of the NBA playoffs
[Crowd cheering]
- [Announcer:] Dunk’s good, Butler.
[Crowd:] Defense! Defense!
- Last night, the Miami Heat
got a huge win over Giannis
and the Milwaukee Bucks.
So it's only right we go
check out their practice.
- [Players talking]
- [Taylor:] You.
- Well, obviously me, but—
- [Taylor:] You. Oooh,
drop the skincare routine.
[Laughing]
- I’m just sayin’, hey.
Hey, don't gas me.
- He better make these.
[Crowd cheering]
Oh, my God.
[Laughing]
- [Whistling]
You healthy, so we don't gotta worry
about no heart attacks.
- Coach!
X! Run X!
- Huh?
- [Man:] Good job, men.
- Good shit, bro.
- [Clapping]
- Andy, man, why you hiding, eh?
- Oh, yeah, Andy, what up?
What up, Andy?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah!
- Thanks for giving us all a heart attack.
- You know, whenever you have that,
you can't key in on just one guy.
We got so many guys that
are constantly working on their game.
They get to pick and choose their spots.
You know, Duncan was huge for us.
Bam was huge for us.
- No—
- Tyler, Goran.
- Can you hurry it up? My back hurts.
- I'm trying. What—
Well, if you wouldn’t do that, your back won’t hurt.
- [Laughing]
- I'm just saying.
[Crowd cheering]
[Whistle blowing]
- If Tacko Fall touches this ball—
- He's gettin' a piece of this.
- [Laughing]
- No, no, no—
- He's getting a piece of this.
- The hoop, you big goof!
The hoop.
[Buzzer]
- Oh, shtuff!
- Oh, did he make it?
- No! He made it!
- Did he make it?
- What?!
No!
- Oh, you're lyin'!
It didn't count, did it?
- No, they gotta, they gotta review that.
I don't think that counts.
- No, 0.5!
- I don't think that counts.
- No!
- Watch, watch.
[Gasping] It did! it did!
- Hey, yo!
- He released it before.
I am so happy you brought the kids, Fred.
- Hi, Sanaa.
- Yeah, daddy-daughter day.
- Hello!
- Say hi.
- Hi.
I love your pink dress. It's so cute!
[Laughing]
- Can you ask her, say “What's your name?”
No, your name is Sanaa.
- Sanaa?
You can come in.
- What's her name?
Watch the cord.
- You wanna be
in the interview, Sanaa?
[Laughing]
- With Doritos on your face?
- Yeah!
- Lemme see.
- Oh, she's precious.
- Shelby got you—
got Doritos all on your face?
- Mmhmm.
- Your mama's gonna kill
me. You know that, right?
- [Laughing]
Well, I'm just gonna
say that at this point,
the playoff Raptors are pretty
synonymous with clutch shots.
- Yeah.
- Wouldn't you say?
- Yeah, for sure, luckily.
- Yeah, luckily, absolutely.
I mean, Kawhi's four-bounce game-winner,
OG's big shot in Game 3.
I mean, what are the
similarities that you saw
between those two shots?
- Crazy shots that nobody
thought were going in.
Last-second buzzer-beaters
in the playoffs are,
you know, kinda rare.
I know it doesn't seem that
way now, being in a bubble,
but historically, it seems rare,
and you don't see many of 'em,
so I'm just glad to be a part of both.
And if you wanna keep
advancing this time of year,
you gotta have some of those.
- Yeah. I mean, you talk
about being a part of both.
It's kinda crazy cuz you were actually
the primary option on OG’s game-winner.
- Yeah.
- I mean, how was it supposed to play out?
- Yeah. Well, in a perfect world,
I would have ran right to the
ball, caught it and shot it.
But, you know, I was able
to draw a little attention,
and I think they fell asleep a little bit,
and OG stepped up and knocked it down.
So, that was big for us, for sure.
- OK, the matchup we wanted to see,
Lakers taking on the Rockets.
Headed to that game right now.
[Crowd cheering]
- [Announcer:] Three-point basket, Harden.
[Intense dramatic music]
[Whistle blowing]
[Clapping]
- This Lakers-Rockets Game
1 gettin' a little chippy.
I think we might see a
brawl or two—not a brawl,
but it's gonna be very aggressive,
this series, I can tell.
[Crowd cheering]
[Whistle blowing]
Leaving the Raptors-Celtics game.
I checked the score for Clippers-Nuggets,
and the Nuggets are up
45-24, end of the first.
Gotta go.
[Intense dramatic music]
- [Announcer:] Nikola Jokic.
[Whistle blowing]
- We are goin' to overtime!
[Crowd:] Defense! Defense!
[Whistle blowing]
- [Announcer:] Threeeee!
[Players shouting]
[Clapping]
- [Announcer:] Anthony Davis!
- OK, definitely been
a rough, like, 24 hours.
Rough time while I'm here in the bubble.
My great uncle passed away.
For those of you that don't know,
Lou Brock is my great uncle.
He was a Hall of Famer with
the St. Louis Cardinals.
One of the best to ever play the game.
But for me, I just lost
somebody that I love dearly.
And one of the best people
that you will ever meet
in your life.
He is kind and genuine
and funny and caring
and made every single
person that he came across
feel like the most important
person in the world.
And while I know some people believe
that his gift was baseball,
I think that was his actual gift:
making all people feel
seen and heard and amazing.
He really did have a knack for that.
But, yeah, so that is what's going on
with me here in the bubble.
Definitely been a rough,
rough, rough time.
But one thing that really
did lift my spirits
was seeing Jayson Tatum,
who is from St. Louis.
He was wearing his Cardinal Jordan 34s.
And he wrote "RIP Lou Brock."
- Obviously, everybody knows he played
for the St. Louis Cardinals.
One of the best players ever in MLB.
One of the best players
to play for the Cardinals.
I'm 22. I never even got to see him play,
but I know what he means
to that organization
and to the city of St. Louis.
And I had the Cardinal
Jordan 34s that I designed,
I had those on today.
And unfortunately, he
passed away yesterday, so,
I just wanted to shed some light on that
for all the people back home.
- Amen, that warmed my heart,
cuz I know my uncle would've loved 'em.
I loved them.
And, yeah, so that was a little,
that was a little light in
a dark, dark couple days.
- You all right?
- Yeah, I'm OK.
[Shouting]
[Cheering]
OK, not only are the Nuggets
winning over the Clippers,
Michael Porter Jr. had one
of best dunks, huge poster.
[Chanting and cheering]
[Whistling blowing]
Hey, Lou. So at a lot of these games,
obviously people have family here,
but it seems like you
all have a big family section.
I  can hear them a
little more than the others.
How does it affect the way you guys play?
Can you hear them the same as we can?
- It's just good to have
a support system here
for a lot of guys.
We came into this bubble with the idea
that we were gonna be
here for the long haul.
We were prepared for the long haul.
I think our families were
prepared for that process as well.
So, we followed through
with them coming here.
Everybody has their support system.
But it's gonna be important
coming down the stretch,
you know, just to have some people.
The lack of fans in the
building, for us to have
a group of people that's
here for us, that's great.
- [Taylor:] But does the
energy feel different now
as opposed to before the families?
- No, you still can't hear 'em for real.
- [Taylor, laughing:] OK.
- It's good to have 'em here, though.
- [Taylor:] All right. Thank you.
[Cheering]
[Whistle blowing]
Double OT, baby!
[Chanting]
[Whistle blowing]
OK, so I might just be hype,
but that was one of the
best playoff games ever!
Double OT. What a showing from
the Raptors and the Celtics.
Even had a bit of a, like,
a weird scuffle, scrum,
in the end when they were
headed to the locker room.
I recorded that.
I also asked Jaylen
Brown what that even was.
Hey, Jaylen, as you guys were heading
back to the locker room,
it seemed like the
teams were exchanging words.
You know, what happened there?
What was that about?
- [Exhaling] You know, a lot of emotions
and things like that
swirling, et cetera.
I ain't gonna really speak
on that too much, you know?
But, you know, it's a lot of emotions,
and it's an intense series.
So, you know, things like
that tend to happen.
- Packing up the spot.
Saying goodbye to the bubble.
Adios.
I'm actually kinda sad.
Game 4, Lakers-Rockets.
It's my final game of the bubble.
I'm so sad.
But right now, it's 26-22,
Lakers. A lot of game left.
Let's see what happens.
[Shouting]
[Cheering]
[Chanting]
Final night in the bubble.
So I wrote an Instagram caption,
but I feel like I need to
share it first with you all,
the viewers of the vlog.
All right, so this is what it says:
In the morning, I leave the bubble.
Heading to St. Louis to be with my family
as we remember the amazing
life of my Uncle Lou.
These two months have
been the most memorable
and important moments of my career.
Hello, world!
I'm here!
There are a few times in life
that you get to be a part
of a first and an only.
- I caught myself.
[Laughing]
- This layered experience
came in the midst
of a country dealing with systemic racism,
police brutality and
a devastating pandemic.
Players sat out. Players
used their voices.
Players battled with an
array of deep emotions
while still competing for a championship.
Every day, I asked myself how to best
do my job to convey this story.
Being deliberate with questions,
taking videos of sounds
and moments that mattered,
but also capturing the joy and
levity that presented itself.
[Upbeat organ music]
- [Announcer:] Three points Lakers!
- One day, people will make movies
and write books about this time.
This was history.
I feel blessed and thankful
that I was able to record history.
[Getting choked up] Whew.
And I'm so thankful to all
of you that followed along.
But there are so many
more games to be played
and more changes to be made.
Peace and love.